ما زال الطالبان ماشيه في فرض قيود
وانتهاك حقوق المراه بشكل كامل فمن وقت ما
استلمت حكومه الحركه الحكم في افغانستان
والقرارات اللي بتخص انتهاك حقوق المراه
ما توقفت من التعليم بنتكلم عن العمل
السفر واللبس وغيرها طبعا كثير فمن اشهر
اصدر الطالبان قرار بمنع التعليم الفتيات
في المدارس الثانويه وفي الجامعات واليوم
بتشدد وبتاكد على هذا القرار فمن المقرر
انه تبدا امتحانات القبول في الجامعات
الخاصه بافغانستان في فبراير وعلشان كده
منعت وزاره التعليم العالي التقدم الفتيات
لامتحان القبول والجامعات الخاصه وكذا
بتكون بتاكد وبتشدد على قرارها اللي صدر
في ديسمبر 20 سنه 2020 واللي منعت خلال
دخول الفتيات الليل للجامعات حتى اشعار
اخر وعلى فكره كانت كمان طلع وزير التعليم
العالي في وقت سابق وقال له رموا عليهم
قنبله ذريه ما راح يتراجعوا عن قرار
[موسيقى]